lady so high limo feed the power
a tsunami who are going to lay back here
two brothers and sisters and dear
friends welcome to this video of warning
sisters against Ali Dawa which is myself
now doing this video is not a matter of
clickbait I actually mean every single
word that I see but I'm gonna put it
into context for you guys and like I
said before what I mean on the title is
what what I said on the tether is what I
actually mean now I received a message
from a sister a couple of days ago
saying that she met a brother she knew a
brother no she was following a brother
on Instagram he would post now dower
stuff you know reminders on a daily
basis and she was an evil dude our post
and our material etc so one day from not
mistaken either she messaged him for
advice etc along those lines or he
message I'm not really sure and what
happened was the reminders were given
forth you know the Brownwood reminder
and I think maybe the sister was going
for a certain issue so she was getting
reminders from bravura every now and
then and then obviously these reminders
kind of continue so a no conversation
started and it's one of the biggest
Fitness when a man and a female a male
and females alone the third person is
Shaitaan with this scenario though it
will just reminders etc but what
happened later on is that this brother
who's basically does Dawa and room in
this tower just as our post here he
basically says to her look I want to
share something with you and can you
give me your basically what's up number
and I will send it to you know it's
beneficial remind etc so she thinks you
know what you know what's the big deal
you know extra shade Sun come to
whispers and says what's the big deal so
she gives a number and then the message
messages her on whatsapp and after that
obviously the conversations carry on
carry on and then this one was starts
asking inappropriate questions etc so
then it comes to a point where they are
going for and the sisters catching
feelings to the brother and vice versa
this what the sister things that you
know he had feelings as well so they
decide to meet up and this brother comes
and he tries to you know be touchy
touchy with the sister and so on so
forth now now both of you are at fault
and I'm we're going to derive some
benefits from this one of the biggest
things a lot of people fall into is that
the broth
is in the Dow scene or he's doing some
kind of Taoist stuff or he looks a bit
religious or he's running a fold or he
has a beard or he goes to the Masjid all
the time and this goes for cities as
well you see a sister who's wearing the
hijab or the abaya or she looks
religious or she looks practicing
automatically what we do is we put our
guards down thinking the person opposite
you is a person that fears Allah and
would never do anything like that now
this is wrong
brothers and sisters and sisters
specifically like I said before I warn
you guys even against myself it should
not mean nothing to you guys that I owe
its brother Ali Dawa even if it's
brother Ali Dawa if you are speaking to
me now I get private messages being
there yeah from sisters and brothers now
for me to be in for me to be in a
private message with you sister is wrong
I'm gonna be straight up I don't need to
lie or beat around the bush but out of
necessity and I keep it short to the
point advice and move on to the best of
my ability now this is the reason why do
because sometimes we do suicidal cases
haram relationship etc and I try to
think myself like if I can benefit this
is to somehow quickly that's it but even
that's a dangerous zone you know so may
Allah protect me from that what like one
of the biggest things that I feel of me
is the food to that to a scene like that
if you are messaging me it should not
matter all is alle da WA it shouldn't
matter if it's one of the men if it's
Moosa if it's Imran if it's whoever
whoever it is no matter if they're a
share or whatever they are if you see me
crossing the limits and lines with you
then you need to say I don't care who he
is
I don't care if he's a lead hour I don't
care how many photos he has I don't care
what he's known for
if he's famous you have to it is a duty
upon you they say brother fear Allah
you're crossing your limits I came to
you for advice
now you're abusing that yeah so you need
to understand sisters specifically as
well is that if I am messaging you or
you are messaging me and I start talking
to you in a way like you know you know
sister yeah so what are you doing
you know what you
up to or join a meet-up you know I think
if Dawa in person you know one-to-one
etc if I start seeing our you know
sister give me a number you know I would
no matter who it is you have to put your
limit there and say but off your law
this is why I warn you sisters even if
it's against myself I have to be real
with you guys and you need to understand
that one of the biggest fitna for a man
is a woman and the Prophet peace be upon
him said the biggest thing that I fear
for my Ummah is women now this does not
mean women are bad or they're evil or
they're this satanic creatures or
whatever no what it means is we have a
desire for women and that is our
weakness I want a society that we live
in today that is even worse just like
for example sisters have a desire and a
weakness for I don't know what Louie
Vuitton bag or nice clothes or for I'm
just giving an example it's just your
weakness doesn't mean that item is
satanic or you know even it doesn't mean
that it means you have a weakness to
that now unfortunately we as brothers in
the Dow scene whoever it me it may be
sometimes we can fall week you know we
are not perfect and mail up Swan Swan
Hotel protect us from that but what you
need to understand processes is that
sometimes sisters take advantage of that
so they know for example there is a
public figure a Brahmas in the Dow scene
so they think you know how can we ruin
this image so what this is okay let's
message him in a flirty manner talk to
him you know do these kind of stuff
that's why a brother so that's why
sometimes as brothers in the Dow scene
we have to be extra cautious and extra
careful because unfortunately there is
female discourse of females as well
there is females out there who are
genuinely have an evil thing in their
heart where they're like oh how can we
catch this brother out and show this
that and that's why I say me I almost
want our protect us from ever falling
from this fitna now the Prophet Mohammed
peace be upon him told us and it's an
advice to you sisters is that when you
are looking for a partner you look for
two things this is for sisters looking
for brother somebody that has religion
and somebody that has manis o'clock good
add up now you need to observe a person
if a person looks religious folk beard
you know he's like wow he's got the
shebang everything's going on like who
is the holy man you know you see the
holy guy now this holy guy that you're
talking about if he starts to talk to
you in a manner which is flirty which is
dirty which he asked you to send
pictures back and forth whatever it may
be you need to say to yourself hold on a
second even if this isn't me like I said
before you need to say hold on a second
now he looks religious okay but he is
asking me really inappropriate questions
you know so you need to draw the line
and say this is wrong
yes he does look religious but his
managers are clocked the ways dinner
would offer example if he's a violent
guy so the Prophet peace be upon him
said look from a religion and man as
they go hand to hand you know and the
Prophet peace be upon him says something
for a reason for the benefit of us so
this is something that we really need to
understand sisters and this goes for
brothers as well because I've had
stories if I stories from people that
are very reliable but as you are looking
for marriage genuinely and they say they
would say okey I'm speaking to a sister
she wears hijab abaya and then she asked
me an appropriate question about a
certain part of my body you know it's I
don't want to go into this what I hope
you guys understand what I'm saying
but the Brahman will see it's quite
unlike I didn't know I just wanted to
turn a blind eye and I fought the best
no you don't do that yes you may assume
the best but if somebody's talking to
you in that manner you really need to
cross the line I think sister feel lost
wanna Tala
you know fear Allah because what you're
saying is now you're crossing limits and
you should not put up with it and think
oh you know this that no that should be
a sign of an alarm bell you know because
if this person could talk to me in this
manner so freely then God knows who she
or he talks to about what so that should
be an alarm bell for all of us
now unfortunately as males as men a lot
of men out there
we tend to think oh she asked for it you
know she she was on it so I started
talking to her like you know if she's
gonna talk to me in a dirty manner like
this that so I'm just gonna take
advantage no it does not give you a
right we are Muslim men it doesn't mean
we're not like people who are dying when
I
she talked to me in a dirty manner yeah
I'm gonna go and use it abuser
no we are Muslim men we fear Allah
subhana WA Ta'ala just because a female
does not respect herself does not mean
I'd love to her Neville and with the
disrespect her we should know better if
I know his sister's coming to me and
messaging me an inbox started talking to
me a flirty manner or sending me
inappropriate pictures even I'm gonna
block her I'm gonna say sister fear
allah subhanho wa taala if i want i can
go along with the flow and take
advantage of your whatever but sister i
see you like my own sister and I and I'm
just seeing this is the beneficial
advice to you sister please what my fear
loss foretell what are you doing it's
causing fitna for me and for yourself
why so this is how a Muslim man should
behave this is how his behavior should
be and may Allah sponsor the makers
among those that would behave
accordingly today not Oh somebody's
messaged me that let me take advantage
of that No and sisters we need to
understand something this genuine
promise out there he were trying to
lower their gaze you know so they could
not fall in you know by looking at you
and not fall in love with you in the
wrong manner in the wrong way if you
know what I'm saying so this bum is out
there genuinely trying to lower their
gaze and do things a halal way sister's
fear allah subhanaw taala
and don't make it hard upon them don't
make it hard upon them by trying to be
flirty trying to send these messages etc
and the same goes for brothers brothers
fear allah subhanaw taala
what if that was your sister imagined
you bothered that listening imagine me
messaging your sister in that flirty man
on telling it to link up with me and
let's do this and that how would you
feel you actually put yourself in the
shoes of another believer it's another
person sister you know how could you so
calmly casually you know lead them along
you know sisters yes sisters do this
they some sense is going make it hard
for practice and brothers etc you know
yes but also there is Brahmas out there
you make it hard for sisters you leave
them alone you lead them along giving
them false promises etc I'm gonna marry
you this time you leave them half way
fear although this is believing women
who want to do things the right way and
they feel like they're trying to lower
their gaze and keep away from zina and
you are coming and giving false promises
and especially we know what's sad is
that you use the tower you use the Dawa
to make yourself look religious so that
says a couple of God's down and think
assume the best in you and what like is
so sad the person is looking at you and
your behavior in public and in YouTube
and thinking good of you and this is the
reason why she's putting her guys now
when she shouldn't and she's thinking
the best of you and thinking you know
that person wouldn't do that look at
that that you have built a trust with an
individual and then you go and drop and
smashed on the floor
by doing what by using your position to
abuse it now brothers and sisters well
why do we need to feel a loss upon wa
taala alice font allah says in the quran
this is the only sin where alice want
allah says don't even go near zina
if you know zina is here and you're
gonna walk just round it Allah says go
around the block not even near it
one of the biggest weakness for men is
women and I almost wanted to protect us
all the brothers away from that fitna
and I are sisters to be protected for
such men who lead you along and like I
said before robbers and sisters do not
look at a woman that she wears hijab or
a buyer and think she's righteous do not
look at a brother who has a be a noise
in the now WA scene always a though this
thing or he must be religion no now when
I mention leads to and I'm not singing
oh there's these religious people about
no sometimes you get people who don't
wear the hijab you what good people some
of them you get that bad
you get hijab is that a good and here
you job is that a bad you get Brahmas
who who for example don't practice
religious some of them a good some of
them are bad and you have promised you
practiced in religion some of them are
good and some of them are bad hope you
guys have benefited they always wanted a
grant every single one of you guys Jenna
inshallah as I'm doing this video I'll
be releasing it I'll be inshallah flying
to Umrah I'll be keeping you guys in my
doors inshallah I will have a vlog out
when I come back showing how Umbra is
done do check that out and also do check
out our new channel hell out dining he
hope you guys have benefited share this
video please this is a really important
topic a lot of people have this
misconception etc so please share this
video and till then insha'Allah
take care of Ramallah for where I'm at
already better care to brothers and
sisters